part d'une auto ça devrait être aligné
au milieu mais est ce que tu as dit à
ton body qui faisait 100 % dis lui qui
fait 100 % à peine rentrée déjà dans le
vif du sujet depuis quelques jours 12
apprenants ont intégré le nouvel axe
escaudes school de nevers lui mois de
découverte des métiers du web taper
quelque chose ça donne quelque chose sur
un site
enfin ça donne un rendu que tu as fais
toi même c'est vraiment excellent jamais
je m'étais dit que je serais
développeurs web mais plus je plus j'en
pratique et puis je me dis que ce serait
pas mal du tout en fait
pas de diplôme requis une formation
gratuite et l'obtention d'un titre
professionnel l'équivalent d'un bac + 2
l'école recrute des profils variés et
ici tout est fait pour intégrer des
compétences directement applicables à la
sortie il ya absolument aucun cours
théoriques
tout se fait en mode projet c'est à dire
que moi j'ai le rôle du client
je demande
un produit ou un service à aux
apprenants qui essaye au mieux de
répondre à ma demande avec une deadline
évidemment comme ça se passerait dans
une entreprise
marinette en reconversion
professionnelle pas d'inquiétude pour la
suite elle sait que le secteur recrute
et que les opportunités sont nombreuses
un sortie du titre professionnel du coup
ça devrait me faire la main en milieu
professionnel tout d'abord et ensuite
des projets différents l'agglomération
de nevers et l'état dans le cadre du
label grandes écoles du numérique
participe au financement
une formation qui s'insère dans
l'environnement créé sur ce site de
l'unfp cube
c'était l'objectif de créer un campus
autour du numérique qui mélange à la
fois les entrepreneurs les salariés les
enseignants les élèves et c'est tout
l'écosystème qui tourne autour du
numérique
sept de ces écoles existent en région
bourgogne franche comté à nevers si la
première session est un succès d'autres
devraient suivre dans le courant de
l'année 2019